sure
what is something you've been struggling
with for years but you can't seem to
overcome it procrastination overthinking
being self-conscious in Social settings
and you've kind of accepted to live with
it you've gotten comfortable but what if
there was a powerful way to trick your
brain into changing it once and for all
Titans like Tim Ferriss successful CEOs
and many high Achievers have used this
to make drastic changes in their life
but a quick disclaimer it's pretty
extreme and I wouldn't recommend
everybody to do it but it works
personally my whole life I've been
struggling with some form of
perfectionism even as a five-year-old I
would wipe my mouth after every single
bite until it was all red and hurting
I've been over brushing my teeth to the
point where I have sensitivity all over
my mouth and I had to get a bunch of
dental work done because of that in
early this year I said we would upload
two videos a month and we have barely
done one a month I'm currently a hundred
thousand dollars Undead because I took
out a loan for this Channel and we
almost went out of business last month
and it's all because of that one thing
that I can't seem to overcome I can't
get going like this
this needs to change what's that
struggle for you that's been holding you
back for years to the point where you
think it's just who you are and you
don't even question anymore what if you
haven't overcome this thing yet because
you've simply accepted it
so check out this graph that I made we
want to be in the happy Zone obviously
it sucks to be in the pain Zone down
here but the worst place to be is the
middle Zone where things are fine see in
the paint Zone we're at least motivated
to get out of it but in the middle we're
not motivated to change and we're not
really happy I've always wanted to
pursue my dreams but you had a
comfortable well-paying career you
didn't like you keep wanting to do this
thing but it's fine if you do it
tomorrow next week next year you don't
have the friends you want but social
media makes you feel kind of connected
some people get stuck here for their
entire life like I have for as long as I
can remember the life I want to create
is impossible if I keep operating this
way if I get lucky something terrible
happens that forces me to change it but
that day may never come unless there is
a way to create it luckily we have the
tickets process
this was popularized by Tony Robbins our
entire life changes in a moment who gets
that say I thanks I'm at a place called
Uncharted Adventures here in Austin and
I'll book The Race room is that weird
now one of my very close friends is
extremely extremely accomplished and he
goes to Unleash the Power Within every
year he's been 11 times maybe 12 now the
Dickens process made the entire event
and easy like 10 to 100 extra turn for
me if you made it this far now is the
time to pay close attention because this
could be a turning point for you if you
decide to go through the exercise with
me in the back of your mind ask yourself
what are you no longer going to tolerate
what Behavior or habit or area of
struggle whatever it is at the root of
it is a single belief that is creating
the problem
in my case if I don't control things
something bad is going to happen now
let's be clear this belief is simply a
choice but I had this trauma and my
brain is just it's just who I am it
doesn't matter where it came from it may
not be your fault but it's now your
responsibility to change that belief now
this is where things get interesting the
goal of the Dickens process is to
increase the pain you associate with
this belief until your face melts so you
have no choice but to let go of it and
therefore you finally overcome this
problem but I already know it's a
painful belief to have so why have not
changed it yet because you haven't
covered all three timelines let me
explain the Dickens process is based on
the Charles Dickens story A Christmas
Carol but this dude is a total dick and
he gets visited by three ghosts past
present and future let's show him one
after the other that you've been in the
past and it sucked even now it's a
problem and look how bad crazy it gets
if you keep being such a dick and then
he realizes he has to stop in it and
he's online we need pain in all three
timelines if we think it'll be fine in
the future we won't change if in the
past it was fine can't be that bad and
if at the moment it's all right then
by asking ourselves a specific set of
questions we cover all three timelines
and create the emotional leverage that
we need
ready to change it
let's Dive In have a look at the belief
or behavior that you picked out what
does this belief cost you in the past
there's things that I'm thinking about
that I don't even want to share on
camera because I feel
third grade and fourth grade I was
terrified of failing at school it really
took the joy out of me as a kid because
I would worry about forgetting my
homework or not passing a test to this
day I have a recurring nightmare of
arriving at school and all my classmates
are ready for the test that they've
studied weeks for and then I'm freaking
out and I'm failing the test that's
deeply ingrained in my brains from years
ago when I was a small kid this is this
has been persistent I'm 27 years old now
it was so debilitating
that that's where my seven years of
insomnia came from as well and with all
that stress does to my health too is so
much damage to my body secondly what is
it costing you right now in the present
the amount of relationships that I've
missed out on I'm so grateful for that
moment where I decided to make a move
with my last girlfriend because it
developed into this beautiful
relationship that we had and so much
growth and there are so many times in my
life where I didn't make that move I see
a girl at a cafe and I have a pimple on
my forehead so it's not right yet
because I don't control this fully the
amount of joy and happiness and
relationships that I've missed out on
every single video takes so much work
it's ridiculous I look back at it and
I'm like why did this take so long why
but it's because it could be better it
could be better and yeah it has many
benefits you have all those benefits
because it's costing me so much
happiness and you may be like oh no
that's not true Leon you're being
negative that's the point of this
there's no like no no it's fine no this
cannot keep going
if you continue holding this belief what
will it cost you in the future five
years from now 10 years from now when I
have kids will I pass that down another
generation really feel the pain do you
still want to hold on to that belief no
we'll double it
[Music]
all the dreams that I have can't be
achieved with the current way that I'm
operating
I'm going to be 30 in three years by
that time I thought I would have it all
figured out I'm still a little kid
inside with this
[Music]
you think you know what that looks like
this is just the beginning
it's painful to change because it's
scary and it takes work so we have to
make it more painful to stay the same
[Music]
to lose
we're not done yet before we get into
the final step that is crucial to make
the change and lock it in allow me to
give an imperfect shout out to element
thanks to element for sponsoring this
video and helping keep the channel alive
I've been using it for over a year and I
absolutely love it for workouts or just
hot days here in Austin to replenish
because this is a sugar-free electrolyte
drink mix that has sodium potassium and
magnesium all essential for Peak mental
and physical performance and just a mild
deficiency can inhibit that and lead to
headaches and fatigue and who wants that
it tastes great and it actually makes me
look forward to workouts so check out
element with a link below we've got a
special offer where you get a free
packet of every single flavor so you can
try them all out and find your favorite
mine it's definitely watermelon and they
offer no questions asked refunds you
don't even have to send it back so it's
a no-brainer go check it out what a
journey final step now that you know how
much this belief sucks choose a new one
just pick one I hope this was helpful
stay different and see in the next one
foreign